you should workshop that joke a little
more it's a little a little bit bassist
welcome to another episode of not your
deep with grace helbig my audio / video
podcast if you don't know by now
seriously what's up here's how it works
I bring on a YouTube friend of mine as a
guest and I interviewed them but it
doesn't get too deep you see part of it
interview here in this video but you can
go over to iTunes or SoundCloud and
subscribe to not too deep with Chris
hope I can hear the interview in its
entirety then here on its grace we play
a game together I take a challenge that
exists on YouTube and I make it dumber
than it already is and you see that here
do you remember when I went to London
earlier this year yeah I don't either
but I did and I got to interview a lot
of really fun British youtubers
including today's guest
sprinkleofglitter Louise God bless her
and now please go see some of that
interview and a game that I call the
boozy challenge it wasn't what you might
think go check it out Louise thank you
for being here you'll welcome grace I'm
very excited about today not as excited
as me well we can have a challenge later
about our excitement okay have you ever
kissed anyone in a library yes really
yes I've never done that
wait was it that you were just so
excited about the book that you were
about to get it wasn't purposeful you're
like let's meet in the library and touch
our mouths together and see what happens
yes really how old are you uh like 19
you're 19 getting too deep not too deep
with grace Helbig though so mustard
question mark I really like it and not
too much of it once I put loads on a
jacket potato because I didn't realize
what mustard was and I thought that my
mouth's on fire and I wanted to scratch
out my esophagus there's a very vivid
story I'm gonna take it back for one
second yeah what this is a jacket potato
what crime would you want to be known
for
diamond thief Oh like out of the Mission
Impossible movies is that what they did
there I didn't see them
yeah there's no Tom Cruise is a tiny
human I used to fancy him so much when I
was like 12
I had a sticker of him I stuck on my
alarm clock so that in the morning so
Chris I also had a sticker that was in
the shape of an arrow and it said he's
mine and I stuck it and pointed it at
him on my alarm clock as if one anyone
ever saw my long welcome to the gay
people were thinking that they would go
out with him now they can't because I
claimed him or my sticker on my alarm
clock
that's how dating works right if you
ever seen this give me a call here don't
because you seem a bit crazy now what
was the most embarrassing high school
memory you have um oh hey look came
across her face as if something very
specific into your brain that you were
trying to forget I haven't ever told
this on the Internet oh my god
I'm excited because I feel like I don't
want to be that girl okay I'll just
summarize it I say we were walking
through the courtyard near my friend
Charlotte and she fell and I found it
really funny right she got up and she
fell again and I found it so funny that
basically I started peeing I was 13 and
because I was so panicked by the peeing
I just sucked down and then everyone
didn't know I sat down and they tried to
pick me up but because I was so panicked
I said my legs didn't work so everybody
called the teachers and the teachers
thought they needed to call ambulance we
can set up some sort of seizure
social I can't get up at all like a pig
was I'll get out together eventually
they're gonna see that this was I can
see my leg started as I said it must
have had a problem with my legs and
that's why my flat
don't look don't look don't look don't
take it all in Walt just nope yah ah ha
what is happening
Louise welcome to your challenge here on
the podcast we take a stupid YouTube
challenge and make it stupider not
possible I've seen those challenges
you haven't seen all the episodes of the
podcast so we are doing a take on the
smoothie challenge but we're playing the
boozy challenge I like it already yeah
here's my theory is that the best way to
get to know someone is over drinks okay
we have a variety of alcoholic and
non-alcoholic liquids in these cups okay
and I have no idea what's in these cups
RPI James we were told him just go get
weird and so how the game works is we
will be asking each other very personal
questions good that my favorite kind
right so if you choose to answer
truthfully the personal question
you can pour anything you want into my
cup okay if you pass because it's too
personal I get to pour into your cup
there is nothing I won't answer oh god
there's a few things I will not answer
I've already got a question for you
though okay
Oh No so the first person to have five
beverages poured into your cup has to
drink the cup and then written on the
bottom of the cups is what's in them so
we'll find out at the very end what we
have consumed do you have any allergies
I should have asked you that before we
yes what are you allergic to penicillin
I'm pineapple did you get penicillin
liqueur we are gonna have to get rid of
a pineapple okay so the poison liquid
has been removed from the tape no
pineapple oh hi uncle surprised one of
them was pineapple
I would have had an anaphylactic shock
this would have been a viral video yeah
next time I won't ask next time and the
beers are here as chaser if what we
consume is disguised out like this so
I'll take yours
dad I throw myself on that bomb for you
out of respect grace do you have a
boyfriend I'm not answering that
this looks sticky great I'm not looking
at what's on the bottom yet we'll put it
over here so we can keep track okay okay
that looks like it could be a variety of
things
Oh Louise have you ever kissed a woman
out of passion no you get to pour
something in Mike mmm why didn't make
these games okay your turn grace mm-hmm
have you ever fought it and blamed it on
someone else yes I get one oh yeah that
looks like that could be human piss
really James took our idea of getting
weird and went the furthest route it's
miles 22 oh yeah all the scents are
coming here smell okay so it's two to
one and this is like golf the lowest
score is really the winner yeah and have
you ever kissed a teacher yes my husband
is a teacher Oh God but why didn't I
research your life more teaching whoa
yeah you created in life with a TP or
d'etre yes
have you ever fancied another youtuber
yes yay yay oh I don't know what that is
I've got my next question lined up ah
okay Louise um have you okay the best
game no it's stupid
um have you ever farted during sex
no someone asked me this question of the
day actually all right we're getting
dangerously close to a Wii oh no looks
download roadie and we're
one more energy drink that thing race
I'm not answering that
Hey Oh God Oh God
Oh Oh God Oh so the bottom okay I'm
gonna drink this because it is my game
and my rules and okay it looks gross
cheers xeu yeah it looks like an STD it
smells awful it honestly uh I'm all yeah
okay huh oh she's got getting all ready
Oh Wendy chaser a chaser
that will help it that will help oh
let's find out what was in the drink
show delicious
I uh I give you an if/else beef was like
liquid it's kind of what it tasted like
as long as it's not in Manila that was
tequila coffee
look cure yeah what kind of status chose
these things ginger ale
that might have been the cloudy one hmm
yeah on that little gross one like Jager
and pina colada mix okay let me thank
you for participating in the boozy
challenge with me welcome I really
enjoyed this if you want to listen to
the full interview with Louise go over
to iTunes and search not too deep with
grace Helbig and go over to
sprinkleofglitter here on youtube and
subscribe to thank you so much for being
here
you're welcome enjoy vomiting now here's
the rest of the ginger ale my body feels
awful yeah what is this no no weird
Croatian schnapps James that was the
podcast with Louise well the video
portion of it you can go on iTunes and
subscribe gosh not too deep with grace
Helbig and listen to the full interview
she said a lot of really fun funny thing
she's a mom and I forgot that based on
some of the things she said see you next
time I don't know